I haven't seen the new episodes yet and
I you know I love that show
it just started last night I haven't
seen the new the start of the new season
yet but I'm completely caught up on the
other seasons and I rewatched one last
night and I thought this is interesting
because it's single camera and you know
here we work with an audience on friends
you work with an audience man with a
plan you work with an audience but on
that show there's no audience did that
when you first started shooting that
after having the friends experience in
the Joey experience is that weird to get
used to he owes a little it was a little
strange because after friends I did Joey
for a couple years then it took like
five or six years off and then went to
do episodes and we shot it in in England
and it's single cameras so that remember
the first thing I shot for the whole
series was this a monologue in the car
with Stephen Mangan who plays Shawn
about how the show within the show pucks
the librarian should not be a lesbian
because if she was a lesbian then
there's no there's less storylines for
my character and her character down the
road I'm gonna make an analogy about how
how long I think friends would have
lasted if Rachel was a lesbian right
right and and there's like a bunch of
jokes throughout the speech jokes yeah I
remember you know thinking okay you get
a hold for the laugh say the one joke
and you take a little pause after about
the third joke is like not one laugh I
remember thinking the back of my head
okay well yeah you should have never
come back you should have stayed in the
bulldozer don't come yeah funny because
I'm only work all I do is work in front
of audiences and I love that but I know
that if I for some reason someone
tragically cast me in something like a
film I'd probably say my line and then
be like
and people no no people would just feel
this is awful cuz you look out look out
where the crowd would be and it's just
the coolest sandwich it's the whole crew
eating one sandwich it's really long
you